die challenge funktioniert nur wenn ihr
mitmacht das heißt wenn ihr bock drauf
habt dass ich diese challenge verlierer
was ich natürlich hoffe dann schreibt so
viele kommentare wie ihr nur können
unter dieses video chat auf jeden
kommentar antworten wenn ich das nicht
schaffe habe ich die challenge verloren
und werde bestraft indem ich eine ganze
packung um getoastet das 1000
und das nur mit einem halben glas milch
und keinem anderen getränk
jo leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer runde kaffeebar bibel
ich weiß nicht was wenn man hinten
machen soll ja wie auch immer ich bin
dabei und dennis steuern 2 punkte und
zwar leute ich mach das video weil es
eine neue challenge geben wird ihr
erinnert euch bestimmt an das
hundefutter video
wer also eine solche change kommt jetzt
wieder ein derartiges video und zwar
werde ich so machen meine challenge ist
es und jeden kommentar auf jeden
kommentar unter diesem video zu
antworten
denkt euch jetzt vielleicht bei das ist
er sehe das ist kein thema für dich ja
aber die sache ist nun ihr könnt das
richtig spannend machen indem ihr so
viele kommentare unter dieses video
schreibt wie ihr könnt schreibt von mir
aus 100 kommentare okay ihr könnt euch
jetzt momentan haben wir gold verpasst
wie gesagt das schreibt zu viele
kommentare wie ihr könnt oder ihr wollt
und meine aufgabe wird sein bis morgen
mittag um 12 alle kommentare zu
beantworten
und jetzt nicht lange gemacht die
geistige holen euro knapp meine aufgabe
wird es sein jeden kommentar vielen
kommentar zu antworten
und ja das wird bisschen trick ja alles
davon ab wie aktiv die in den
kommentaren seite wenn jetzt wenn ich
jetzt 8 kommentare habt dann ist es
natürlich locker iso dann muss ich auch
nicht bestrafen gibt keine bestrafung
wenn er allerdings jetzt
1000 kommentare schreibt oder so dann
wird schon schwer für mich macht man so
zwei wunder denn dann wird schon schwer
und was machen wir jetzt meine
bestrafung ich weiß nicht was es nicht
ist es eine gescheite bestrafung sechs
scheiben toastbrot zu essen ohne oder
was zu trinken
weißt du wie trocken
ungethüm getoastet ja und was zu trinken
er ist ja klar wie trocken ist dein mund
macht ja und völlig sechs scheiben eine
komplette packung bist du krank
der komplette partie wenn ich es nicht
schaffe auf jeden kommentar zu antworten
ich war davon ein video machen mit
bildschirmaufnahme oder so wie es habe
ich zeige ja jeder kommentar antwortet
ihr wisst bescheid dann oh gott ich kann
einfach nicht die facebook schauen
zocken dann es sich eine ganze packung
tosun getoastet und ohne was zu trinken
mit einem halben glas wollte allein was
es für mich ausgewählt
also leute noch mal die challenge
funktioniert nur wenn ihr mitmacht das
heißt wenn ihr bock drauf habt dass ich
diese challenge verliere was ich
natürlich hoffe dann schreibt so viele
kommentare wie ihr nur können unter
dieses video stellt auf jeden kommentar
antworten wenn ich das nicht schaffe
habe ich die challenge verloren und
werde bestraft indem ich eine ganze
packung um getoastet desto besser und
das nur mit dem halben glas milch und
keinem anderen getränk das wird die
hölle
das wird so allen es wird die ganze
sache ist dann ohne irgendwie ein glas
wasser zu kommen nein jetzt habe ich
langsam temperaturen machen wenn du
gewinnen
okay leute das ist viel
die fette musik kommt wie ihr wisst
bescheid die runde ist vorbei da würde
ich sagen also dass ich zum abschluss
noch mal zusammenfassen die technisch
besteht darin dass ihr die kommentare
schreibt und ich auf einen kommentar
antwortet wenn ich es nicht schaffe dann
eine packung post für mich mit dem
halben glas mich wenn ich es schaffe ist
dennis die ganze packung ungetestete
stores roth mit einem halben glas milch
und muss es auf der webcam aufzeichnen
also leute wenn ihr darauf bock drauf
habt schreibt viele kommentare so viel
erkennt unter dieses video und macht's
gut leute servus und hallo